first of all this year marks 10 years
since we've been introduced to loki
wrap your head around that tell me what
that what is that like for you
10 years developing making this iconic
character
well first of all thank you so much for
having me and for saying that
um it has it's been a source of constant
surprise and delight that i've played
this character for so long
i i had no idea when i auditioned that i
would be sat here 10 years
down the road and and still doing it
and i feel very grateful to to the to
marvel studios and also to the audience
who seem to be interested in him still
and
i wouldn't be here without them i know
what this place is
[Music]
the timekeepers have built quite the
circus
and i see the clowns are playing their
parts to perfection
big metaphor guy i love it makes you
sound super smart
i am smart i know i'm sort of very
appreciative of the fact that loki is so
complex
so every time i come back to play him
i'm like
right let's have a look at this bit you
know he's like got all these little
interesting facets and aspects to him
i feel quite lucky that i'm able to just
keep digging i suppose yeah
been an amazing ride and you're doing
such a remarkable job
like you said as a loki is a a dynamic
character
it is adorable that you think you could
possibly
manipulate me talk to me about like what
is the exploration
of loki you know the the exploration of
grief you kind of get in one division
exploration of identity you kind of get
from
winter soldier in its own way
i think it's about
the exploration of
reality and an identity
as in it's almost as a question about
are we the the captains of our own
destiny are we masters of our own fate
do we have free will
are we just rolling down tracks that
have been laid out
for us by either our past or or you know
is there such a thing as
as true agency can we make our own
choices
if you can and then you have to take
responsibility for those choices
and then that's how you in in turn start
creating
different realities i'm taking some
place to talk but i don't like to talk
but you do like to lie which you just
did because we both know you
love to talk not keep talking
how long have you been here i don't know
it's hard to say you know time passes
differently here in the tva
what does that mean sorry to get a
little deep there but it kind of
it kind of hears about that because this
is about a series about time and
the idea of a timeline that's been
preordained
by somebody else and that can be that
would be very destabilizing
if either you or i found that out that
actually
whatever we plan to do tomorrow wasn't
our idea it was some idea that somebody
else had had and we were just
stepping into it you know the idea that
your little club decides the fate of
trillions of people across all of
existence at the behest of three
space lizards yes it's funny it's absurd
i thought you didn't like to talk how
big a fan of you were owen before you
guys got to work together because you
guys are just have this
amazing chemistry he he is brilliant
um and i think i think he's done
you know i don't know exactly how many
years he's been working as an actor but
but
there are so many performances of his
that i've admired from a distance
and certainly as a young actor his work
with
wes anderson is is i think like
absolutely at the kind of apex of those
kinds of films and
and he's always brought this
extraordinary
curiosity and intelligence to what he
does he can do the comedy and it can be
sometimes
he can lean into the broad stuff but he
can also do the really precise nuanced
stuff and
and he's just a really interesting man
and he brought so many brilliant ideas
to this and and
mobius his character is an analyst at
the tva he's kind of an academic and
he's curious about loki
but he's not persuaded by loki's old
tricks
so it's a really the dynamic between
them is this
kind of odd couple they have this odd
couple chemistry
where they need each other but they're
not sure if they can trust each other
and when you sort of have to see they're
both playing chess with each other and
you see where it goes
but owen is great and i can't wait for
everybody to see what he does is mobius
you